as we been doing every night on out
front we have another exclusive dispatch
from the journalist ibrahim dach he is
inside gaza ibrahim family as you know
moved from the north to the south and
they were hopeful that they would
finally be able to escape through egypt
those hopes for now still hopes not yet
successful ibrahim and his wife rasha
and their two young sons age 11 and s
evacuated nor gaz israel told
toed they to the south and now
هل سنموت
اليوم هذا ما يسالني عنه ابني منذ ان
هربنا من مدينه
غزه الحمدلله على السلامه الحياه في خانون
الصعب نحن نقيم مع ما لا يقل عن 150 عائله
نازحه اخرى من الشمال ناكل فقط ما يكفي
لبقائنا على على قيد
الحياه نقضي وقتنا في متابعه الضربات
[موسيقى]
الجويه ومحاوله ملء خزان المياه بنشرب من
ميه الحمامات والله يا عبير والله اولادنا
بشربهم من ميه
الحمامات وبسبب انقطاع
الكهرباء لا يستطيع ابنائي مشاهده الرعب
عبر
الانترنت ويقضون وقتهم في اللعب مع
الاطفال الاخ
[تصفيق]
ل خلال نهايه الاسبوع وصلتنا رساله انه تم
السماح لنا بالدخول من معبر رفح لذلك قمنا
بتحميل سيارتنا لمحاوله الفرار مره
اخرى في الطريق الى هناك كان الكثير من
الضمار عند المعبر كانت هناك عائلات اخرى
مليئه بالامل تحاول ايضا الهروب يلا لكن
هذا الامل تلاش
بسرعه قيل لنا انه مغلق الان ولم يتمكن
احد من
المرور كنا في معبر رفح وانتظرنا على امل
انه ندخل الجانب المصري لكن المعبر مغلق
فتح فقط للمساعدات
الانسانيه نشق طريقنا للرجوع متفا
الفوضى على امل ان يكون الغد افضل من
اليوم
نسمع الغارات الجويه على
مسافه
خايف
مشف ولكني ارى الرعب في
عينيه نفس الخوف الذي في
عيني hing to be able to